bientôt disposer journée stressante mais
les agents drian 2000 à tort la version
6.8 j'ai dit un chiffre au hasard et on
va créer sempai ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas créé sympa y aller lancom
aspirine avec un crâne rasé parce qu'on
adore one woman la couleur des cheveux
du bus très important qu'on n'a pas de
chevaux des petites lunettes 3d allez
c'est parti
c'est l'homme de nos rêves comme
d'habitude on change pas la tradition
aujourd'hui sera la culotte samouraï
ok alors première étape allait prendre
la nouvelle arme ou une véranda
maintenant sur 2 qu'il fout là elle
attend ce pas normal ça t'as vu c'est
une rebelle noël peut pas c'est pour ça
qu'elle est là elle est perdue et le
trouve plus le chemin qui est cette
personne juge ça c'est là la chef d'un
club hockey et ses clubs de quoi le club
des gens qui vont mourir elle est
blanche mais conduire azumi avait jointe
au club c'est le club de jardinage si je
vais en revanche peut transporter des
équipements de jardinage partout sans
paraître étrange mais c'est fantastique
ah bah oui je sais vous qu'on va en
avoir besoin au super la dernière fois
ça fail cette fois vous en faites pas
savoir regarder et la caisse qu'on a une
si j'ai peur que ça marche pas la
circulaire autrement appelée elle
décapite atolls de la moelle t c'est un
nom un peu long ok on peut pas
l'arranger les vu que je fais partie du
club je ne paraît pas suspect c'est
vraiment un endroit pour décapiter
quelqu'un sous le soleil du coup
maintenant ce qui nous manque c'est
quelqu'un on va se mettre enfin voila ma
[ __ ] ma place et mbaye sur ses pas et
moi aussi j'ai pas de cheveux vient au
il ya un chef de clubs là qu'est ce
qu'il fait lui tu m'emmerdes c'est pas
moi non mais non mais pourquoi - vous
avez ou un non j'ai déconné je n'ai pas
fait exprès oh merde il ya la preuve
qu'ils arrivent à temps et ce qu'on peut
pas se cacher vers la porte attaqué la
prof
j'peux la merde et lâchement crâne
chauve [ __ ] je le poly tous les soirs
se bat pour tulle abymes on va faire ça
dans les règles de l'art ne vous en
faites pas aller dépêchez vous les
enfants je suis homo professeur d'arts
plastiques
moi j'attends juste buts et le dernier
c'est bon c'est lui regarder ce personne
ne voit personne ne voit non c'est faux
c'est pas moi non non non c'est parce
que vous
[Musique]
écoutez on va commencer par aller en
cours night club musique ça change et ça
au we ll nous suisse va aussi me
regardait les membres de tous les clubs
à la foire bonne jours il faut qu'on
mette des points dans l'éducation
physique vous allez voir pourquoi ok
c'est parti alors là logiquement j'ai
mis tellement de points dans l'éducation
physique que j'ai les bras de teddy
riner est toi je veux te demander de me
suivre s'il te plaît attendez d'un
bandeau elle fait partie du club c'est
le mauvais plan allait mais coincés par
asa à le faire à l'école louise mis à
l'essuie mois 6 mois surtout n'ai pas
peur vient dans la cabane
je suivais jamais quelqu'un dans une
cabane au milieu de nulle part ou prend
la circulaire vient avec moi toujours
bon je crois pas pas tant à faire là bas
sous les eaux la coupe en deux et la
regarder ce qu'on peut faire c'est
fantastique la prendre dans nos bras
parce qu'on a les biceps de teddy ricoul
a eu une position foetale lévita sionnel
lesparre ah ben on va ensuite l'amener
dans la petite véranda minium hélas la
violence extrême devant les herbes en
forme de kaka ça ne rigole plus
maintenant on peut aussi mettre une
caméra externe c'est quoi la touche cfc
après c'est exactement ce que vous
pensez on est en train de décapiter
cette pauvre femme voilà attend c'est un
être vivant sa botte et on peut
maintenant et ça c'est le mieux prendre
voilà des partis pour vraiment faire un
petit cadeau par exemple la cnpa y
attend la tête c'est mieux la tête et
beaucoup mieux s'est fait un petit
cadeau pour toi l aveu qui fit for you
yeah samedi le moule ça me paraît
surpris saint pie
c'est pas sympa et [ __ ] c'est tromper
pardon pardon tu n'es pas sympa la
preuve c'est pas du général [ __ ] le
ton et l'immense maintenant witham
paille puisque ça peut être veut pas ma
tête je te l'offre à toi cette tête se
trouve un centre tessa on peut aussi
faire quelque chose de très amusant la
lâcher comme une énorme merde
adios
on va tuer du titan zoulou et textures
[ __ ] ils sont bons à temps est-ce que
je peux genre vraiment compter sur sa
jambe et tous il est arrêté de tweets et
les titans venez vous battre
aussi je peux forcément attaquer une
pomme de terre aux mondiaux à tanger
carlo mon dieu je savais qu appliquer
[ __ ] le titan est tombé tyson foods
tétouan la cité toi n'ont rejoint le
bataillon d'exploration elle pourra pas
l'avoir si oh tu peux pas entrer pouces
tu fais pas partie du club au ou la
brein on est trop fort
[Musique]
suis moi vraiment il va t'arriver bien
la vierge suis désolé j'ai vraiment
besoin de ton buste voilà la fête à la
bonne taille de psychopathe saf
alors qu est ce qu on lui prend le torse
une jambe ça partait c'est sympa et
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent avec une jambe
à par assommer des gens moi je dirais un
bras un bras d'or c'est pareil c'est
pire une tête ou à temps elle est une
tête d'une tête c'est vraiment le truc
bien sale c'est pas joli cadeau pour toi
il est la seule assise sur la fontaine
ses feuilles
puisque tu te fait pas j'ai monté la
tête une au fait tu nous faisais bras
patate toledo il me semble qu'il ya de
la nouveauté au niveau du club celtic
c'est faux au niveau du club occultes r
reach naïve quoi attend ça fait quoi ce
couteau là faut que tu quelqu'un là
dessus on va demander à quelqu'un nous
suit on va l'amener dans la pièce du
club
bizarre et on va le but et on est avec
le couteau blizzard a au milieu du
cercle bizarre ce fait beaucoup de
bizarreries ta gueule au no je me tue à
10h au non pardon pardon mais du coup je
vais faire un sacrifice énorme et je
suis désolé leader je voulais vraiment
faire un sacrifice pour toi mais tu t'es
mis entre moi et la personne allez ça va
allez viens avec moi petit leader ça va
aller je vais t'emmener à l'infirmerie
voilà est-ce que ça va mieux qu'ils ne
répondent pas qu'on sort alors si on
attend juste qu'il soit 17 heures et
qu'on fait l'activité du club est ce qu
il va se passer un truc je suis sûr que
c'est un truc tout made qui a pas marché
voilà on a essayé d'invoquer un démon ça
va pas marcher
super car on va vers le plus gros
sacrifice de l'histoire de cette école
alors écoute moi bien espèce de leader
claquettes eu tout un coupé en deux
voilà comme ça tu vas te calmes et toi
tu vas te calmes et toi tu mets ta drame
prier
[Musique]
mais je suis confiant je n'ai pas tué
avec le couteau bon allez j'ose dire
dans cette ville aux brillantes des
résonateurs n'y avait pas énormément de
voter si ce n'est la scie sauteuse 1
comme on l'appelle scie circulaire lucas
g passionna plus c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas même de haut comme d'habitude je
suis déçu voilà je voulais évoquer un
démo pour soumettre son bail
ça n'a pas marché alors sur une
prochaine vidéo porter ou bien un job du
monde by sa
je sais pas
et carlucet